IF YOU TELL EVERYONE YOU ARE
DOING A THANKSGIVING WITHOUT
TURKEY SOME GUESTS WILL DROP OFF
THE LIST AND THAT WILL CUT
COSTS.
>> HERE IS A COLUMNIST AND A FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
MONICA, THEY ARE THEY OUT OF
TOUCH THAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN PEOPLE SEE THEIR LIVES
CHANGING AND HOW FAR THEIR MONEY
GOES IT DOES MATTER.
>> THEY HAVE TRIED TO DEFINE
INFLATION AND MINIMIZE IT.
WE HEARD FROM THE HAVE THE AND
THE VICE-PRESIDENT AND JEN PSAKI
AND THE CHAIR OF THE FEDERAL
RESERVE AND THE TREASURY
SECRETARY JANET YELLEN CALLING
INFLATION TRANSITORY WANT DON'T
WORRY:
IT'S TEMPORARY.
THE FED TODAY SAID INFLATION
MIGHT NOT BE THAT TRANSITORY.
THEY DON'T REALLY CARE THAT
AMERICANS ARE BEING SQUEEZED BY
HIGHER PRICES.
IT'S DONE IN THE NAME OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL TRANSFORMATION OF
THE NATION.
THEY HAVE A BROADER AGENDA HERE
TO REMAKE THE ECONOMY AND
REENGINEER THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THE ECONOMY.
IF THE AMERICANS HAVE TO FORE GO
TURKEY AND HAVE A HOT DOG
INSTEAD, IT'S WORTH IT BECAUSE
THEIR AGENDA IS MUCH MORE LONG
RANGE AND LONG-TERM.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BOTHER JOE
BIDEN WHO SITTING IN
A BILLIONAIRE'S COMPOUND IN
NANTUCKET.
>> THAT'S WHAT THE LEFT DOES.
THEY TELL US TO LOWER
EXPECTATIONS.
GETTING USED TO DEALING WITH
LESS.
WE ARE DOING BETTER AND BIGGER
THINGS, PASSING TRILLION
DOLLARS.
HOW DARE YOU QUIBBLE OVER
A COUPLE OF DOLLARS?
>> IT WOULD BE INTERESTING IF IT
JUST WAS THE TURKEY.
YOU HEARD JEN PSAKI SAYING WELL,
IT'S THE TURKEY ABOUT A DOLLAR
MORE FOR 20 POUNDS.
IT'S A LOT MORE THAN THAT.
IT'S EVERYONING COSTS MORE NOW.
IT'S NOT JUST THE TURKEY.
MONICA WAS SPOT ON.
THEY TOLD THEY WANT TO TRANSFORM
AMERICA.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE AMERICA FROM
THE INSIDE-OUT AND TAKE AWAY OUR
TRADITIONS.
IT MIGHT SEEM RIDICULOUS.
DON'T HAVE A TURKEY AND PEOPLE
WON'T COME OVER.
LAST YEAR THEY DIDN'T WANT US TO
GET TOGETHER.
WE ARE LUCKY THEY ARE LETTING US
THIS YEAR.
THEY WANT TO DIVIDE AMERICANS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO US HAVE
COMMON GROUND OR SHARED
TRADITIONS LIKE THANKSGIVING.
A LOT OF PLACES LAST MONTH DID
AWAY WITH HALLOWEEN.
THEY WANTED TO BE INCLUSIVE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T CELEBRATE
HALLOWEEN.
THAT'S A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE.
IT ALL GOES TO FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORMING THIS COUNTRY AND
THE WAY YOU DO THAT IS YOU MAKE
SURE WE HAVE NO COMMONALITYIT
AND NO TRADITIONS.
YOU CHIP AWAY.
THEY DON'T CARE THAT
THANKSGIVING COSTS MORE --
WHETHER DRIVING TO SHOULD BE'S
HOUSE OR PAYING FOR THE FOOD ON
THE TABLE.
JOE BIDEN IS VERY HAPPY RIGHT
NOW WHERE HE IS FOR
THANKSGIVING.
>> I TAKE ISSUE WITH THE FACT
THAT HALLOWEEN AND TRICK OR
TREATING NOW HAPPENS DURING THE
DAY.
BACK IN THE DAY IT HAPPENED AT
NIGHT.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE SPOOKY.
I DIGRESS.
MIRANDA, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MEDIA.
INFLATION IS NOT THAT BIG OF
A DEAL.
HAVE COVID TESTS FOR PEOPLE AT
YOUR THANKSGIVING MEAL.
THEY GO TO NO END TO WANT TO
COVER-UP.
HOW FAR CAN THEY GO TO MAKE THIS
SEEM LIKE IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL?
>> YOU ARE SO RIGHT.
IT'S LIKE A GIANT GAS LIGHTING
OPERATION.
IT COMES FROM THE MEDIA AND THE
WHITE HOUSE AND FROM JOE BIDEN
HIMSELF.
IT'S NOT WORKING.
YOU JUST LOOK AT THE POLLS.
YOU SEE THAT AMERICANS ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
INFLATION.
THEY ARE WORRIED APPROXIMATE
THEIR POCKETS AND GAS PRICES AND
THE DIRECTION THE COUNTRY IS
GOING IN -- AND THEY BLAME JOE
BIDEN.
THEY SAY HE PRETENDED HE WAS
GOING TO HEEL  -- HEAL THE
DECISIONS IN THE COUNTRY AND HE
HASN'T DONE.
THE POLLS ARE GOING DOWN THE
TUBES FAST.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE.
THE OPTICS ARE BAD OF HIM GOING
OFF FOR 5 DAYS FOR HOLIDAY IN
ONE OF THE MOST EXCLUSIVE RESORT
ISLANDS IN THE WORLD AT A $30
MILLION COMPOUND.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
THIS IS A TIME WHEN THE ECONOMY
IS REELING FROM SELF-INFLICTED
CRISES.
ALLOWED TO GO ON HOLIDAY BUT
THIS IS WHO HE IS.
HE AND HIS FAMILY THIS LIVED
A LIFE OF LUXURY AND PRIVILEGE
UNIMAGINABLE TO MOST AMERICANS.
THEY ARE STARTING TO REALIZE
THIS.
IF THE DEMOCRATS THINK THEY WILL
RUN IN 2022 ON TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYND  -- SYNDROME THEY WILL GET
A SHOCK.
DONALD TRUMP IS ALREADY BEATING
BY ALMOST 10 POINTS.
>> YOU CREATE A BUFFER OF